over the years the decades now and i  look at my portfolio of companies that  have been successful and those that have  failed 75 of my returns over the last 15  years  have come from companies run by women  one of my ceos a woman that was running  an online wedding business where she was  basically originating about 500 million  dollars worth of gifts  to brides grooms and bridesmaids and  fantastic business very profitable and  she told me you know kevin most people  during their day  spend two thirds of their time talking  only one third of their time listening  she said why don't you reverse it why  don't you try shutting up and listen  two-thirds of the day  and talk one-third you'll become far  more powerful you'll become far better  at investing the key to success that i  would have taught myself 20 years ago  would have been shut up and listen